Political correctness,
the seems to be taking up more and more space now when you've been quite vocal
against it,
but it feels like a lot of people don't really understand what it is.
It is often mixed up with common courtesy.
For an example,
can you define political correctness for us?
Why is it not,
not good?
Well,
political correctness I would say is fundamentally a collectivist doctrine and
collectivist doctrines insists that the proper way of parsing up the world is
through the lens of group identity.
So you could think about it as the,
as part of the expression of identity politics,
which is something that script the left,
probably something that cost Hillary Clinton the election law in the United
States in the last election cycle.
And so,
and the the people who are politically correct insists that individuals are
basically avatars of their group and that the world is a battle ground of groups
vying for dominance,
power competition.
It doesn't matter who you are as an individual,
it's only what group you belong.
Yes,
well,
I would say in in within the confines of the politically correct doctrine,
there aren't individuals.
There are only groups vying for power.
That's why the politically correct types oppose free speech.
It isn't that they oppose it.
It's worse than that.
It's that from within the confines of the politically correct doctrine.
There's no such thing as free speech because what you claim as your free speech
is actually nothing but your justification of the hierarchy that gives your
group dominance.
That's everything from the politically correct perspective and so there's no
real possibility even for dialogue between well meaning individuals because
there's no such thing as dialogue to begin with and there's no such thing as
well meaning individuals and so it's almost impossible to overstate how
pernicious that doctrine is.
It demolishes the idea of individual sovereignty and the possibility of
communication across individuals.
That's why it produces ideas like
cultural appropriation because there's no,
all that happens.
If you utilize the artifacts of another culture,
it isn't that you admire the more that it's a part of trade or that is part of
the free expression of ideas.
It's that your taking away the artifacts of power from that other group in an
attempt to foster your own group dominance.
Everything's viewed through that lens as if I,
if I would dress up as an Indian for a costume party.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's,
you know that that sort of thing has caused all sorts of trouble in American
universities where because their end and they've produced about Halloween
costumes,
I mean it's absurd in many ways as if the dressing up in Mexican national
uniform,
let's say national clothing or Dutch national clothing for that matter is some
kind of insult.
It isn't an insult and even if it was,
that's Halloween,
is it time to break rules?
That's the whole point of the,
of the,
of the celebration.
So political correctness has corrupted the university.
So lots fields as far as I'm concerned it has.
And the universities are doing everything they can to corrupt other institutions
and their,
and the other institutions are foolishly going along for the ride.
So you see,
for example,
and this is probably more true in the u s than anywhere else,
although also in Canada,
Australia as well,
that corporations are under the pressure of this politically correct fostering
of guilt are admitting despite the fact that there's no scientific validity for
this claim whatsoever,
that their employees are on Mohs,
structurally racist,
and that people are viewing the world through the lens of implicit bias and that
we're all fundamentally racist and that that should be rectified through like
reeducation.
So,
um,
what unconscious bias retraining programs for which there is,
there is no evidence whatsoever that those programs work and it's a substantial
amount of evidence that they're counterproductive.
And the implicit association test that has been put forward hypothetically to
diagnose,
uh,
racism.
Implicit racism is not a valid or reliable test and cannot be used for those
purposes.
And even the makers of the test,
Brian Nosek and Anthony Greenwald have admitted publicly that their test is
being misused.
All of that's,
it's all of that.
That's extraordinarily dangerous.
And if corporate executives had any sense,
they would stop rushing to admit that are corporations are structurally racist.
It's a very bad idea.
And this is all under the influence.
You say off postmodernism and neo meal monks,
those things,
two separate things,
they're completely separate.
You know,
and this is something I've been criticized for.
Dr. Peterson doesn't understand the difference between neo Marxism and
[inaudible] and postmodernism.
It's like I understand the difference perfectly.
Well it isn't me that's conflating them.
It turns out that the people who push postmodern doctrines in the university
almost always ally themselves with the Marxist viewpoint and that is logically
incoherent.
But I would say the postmodernists really don't give a damn for logical
coherence because they regard that as part of the oppressive Patriarchal
Eurocentric view of the world.
The idea that there's an objective reality and all of that and that you can deal
with it with logic.
Um,
I think that there is a,
an alliance between the postmodern types and the Neo Marxists.
And as far as I can can tell,
when I looked at the development of postmodern ideas,
which,
which really came to prominence in France,
it was all failed Marxists who pushed the doctrine forward.
And I think it's,
it's a wolf in sheep's clothing.
Identity politics is just Marxism under a different guise.
So instead of the narrative being the privileged economic class,
the z against the proletariat that didn't sell so well and produce tens of
millions of deaths,
that fundamental narrative,
there was this slight of hand and said,
well,
it's not economic class.
It's race or it's gender or ethnicity or it's sex,
but it doesn't matter because the fundamental narrative is still victimizer
versus victim.
And so it's Marxism under another guise.
And the fact that postmodernists technically are skeptical of Meta narratives
like large scale explanatory structures should mean that they're equally
skeptical about Marxists claims because that's a grand narrative.
But in practically speaking,
that isn't how it works out.
And so this alliance does exist,
even though conceptually it's completely incoherent,
says,
I really don't believe that the post,
that postmodernism is something in and of itself.
I think it's a,
it's a camouflage for,
for Marxism under another name.
And these ideas of yours,
they are the ones that gain you the largest groups of enemies and,
and you,
yes.
Well,
the thing is the left is the radical leftist types.
And I would say they're the leftist collectivists and I'm,
by the way,
no fan of right wing collectivists.
So either it's just that they don't threaten the universities.
There's no right wing collectivists in the universities.
Like none.
There's no right wingers,
there's no conservatives.
There are hardly any liberals in most of the,
in most of the activists,
uh,
disciplines.
Um,
yeah,
the radical left types don't like me at all.
And that's okay because the feeling is mutual.
I think that the veil,
they can orchestrate vicious attacks and hit pieces in the biggest media as
well.
And I've been,
you know,
I've had the full gamut of treatment in the media.
I would say in Canada for example,
there's a handful of outstanding journalists who act as individuals.
Um,
a dozen of them,
let's say a maybe slightly less than that,
and they've been firmly supporting me the whole time.
And the post media group in Canada,
which was a consortium of 200 have newspapers,
came out in favor of my free speech stance in relationship to bill [inaudible].
And so I've been treated very well by the,
by some elements of the media,
but it's definitely the case that I've also been pilloried as a and caricatured
and stereotyped as a,
as an outright figure,
I suppose.
Sometimes there's a far right figure for that matter by,
by venues that have,
that should have known much that of should have known better.
And BC did a terrible video hit piece on me.
It was an appalling piece of,
of careless,
provocative journalism.
It was,
it,
it was.
They were exposed.
Very,
why was it was,
I couldn't believe it when I watched it.
I thought,
not only are you people crooked,
but you're stupid and incompetent.
You should get one of those things right.
He shouldn't be all three of those things at the same time.
They interviewed me for 90 minutes and it was a contentious interview conducted
by a narcissistic interviewer,
and then they chopped it into like a three minute teaser that was just outright
falsehoods.
And then people on Youtube took the actual interview and the edited version and
juxtapose them showing that they'd actually reversed the meaning of some of the
things I said.
I sold it to so and,
but so far the attacks have been,
I would say highly counterproductive.
And I've been in this very strange situation,
which I have.
No,
I have,
I mean,
I feel that it's a tenuous situation that every time there's been a protest,
say against my appearance on the university campus,
which has happened many times,
or an attack piece,
then like it's very stressful and,
and the potential for damaging my reputation appears high.
But that medium to longterm consequence of that is that the journalists end up
more discredited than me.